bonsoir et bienvenue à tous ravis de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir le ministre de la transition
numérique bonsoir Jean-Noël Barrault
merci d'être notre grand témoin vous
venez tout juste de présenter votre
projet de loi pour sécuriser et réguler
l'espace numérique c'est un défi en soi
mais est-ce vraiment possible alors ou
un Français sur deux est victime d'une
tentative d'arnaque sur Internet et même
le site de l'Assemblée a été récemment
piraté vous allez nous dire dans la
deuxième partie tout ce que vous
proposez mais on va commencer ce soir
avec la reconquête industrielle Emmanuel
Macron en a fait la mère des batailles
le président à l'Élysée avantée ses
résultats devant un parterre de chef
d'entreprise tout à l'heure alors la
France certes recréer de l'emploi
industriel mais par de plus loin que ses
voisins européens quels sont nos atouts
stratégiques est-ce que le
protectionnisme fait partie de la
solution grand débat dans un instant
avec nos invités sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris et puis dans Bourbon express ce
soir l'indignation à l'Assemblée après
la démission du maire de Saint-Brévin
victime d'intimidation de l'extrême
droite voilà pour le menu ce soir vous
me suivez monsieur le ministre ça vous
regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
la réindustrialisation bataille
économique mais aussi géopolitique et
même
identitaire a dit Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui le rapport à l'industrie est
une part d'explication du mal français
on va revenir ce soir sur les mots le
message du chef de l'État le
protectionnisme manifestement n'est plus
un gros mot dans notre pays bonsoir
Laurent Saint-Martin ravi de vous
retrouver vous êtes le directeur général
de business France l'agence publique
destinée à faire venir les investisseurs
étrangers dans notre pays et vous êtes
ancien rapporteur général du budget ici
à l'Assemblée ancien député Renaissance
en face de vous Aurélie trouvez bonsoir
merci d'être là député la France
insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis ancienne
présidente du Collectif attaque bonsoir
Philippe à Lyon bonsoir grand plaisir de
vous retrouver économiste professeur
d'économie au Collège de France à la
londonchool avec un amix de Londres et à
l'INSEAD à Fontainebleau enfin bonsoir
Marc Lhermitte merci d'être avec nous ce
soir vous êtes associé chez einste and
young Iwan en bon français qui publie
aujourd'hui sont classement de
l'attractivité des pays européens on va
y revenir dans le détail évidemment il
est pour vous ce débat Jean-Noël
Barrault le numérique c'est un des
grands leviers de la reconquête
industrielle donc évidemment vous faites
partie de ce débat ce soir je vous donne
la parole dans un instant qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit le président exactement la
reconquête est-elle en marche il a 200
secondes c'est le défi de Blacko
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
mon cher Stéphane comme chaque soir
Bonsoir à vous bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à
toutes et tous alors l'emploi industriel
en France alors je sais pas si vous êtes
au courant mais en ce moment là on est
en plein compte à reboursé 100 jours
pour tourner la page de la réforme des
retraites il a dit ça à 36 jours il en
reste 64 et aujourd'hui il avait une
bonne nouvelle sur laquelle s'appuyait
qui a été publié par le cabinet herse
hey young c'est regarder le fait que
pour la quatrième année de suite la
France et le pays d'Europe qui attire le
plus d'investisseurs alors moi naïvement
j'aurais été tenté de pousser un petit
cocorico mais le position est
manifestement beaucoup moins naïve on
écoute Alexis Corbière quel est
l'objectif il est politique de changer
la conversation on parle quasiment plus
des retraites alors qu'on est encore
dans un mouvement des retraites et il
nous montre les mérites de son action
politique on réindustrialise le pays
léger frémissement à l'image de ce qui
se passe en Europe où nous on n'est pas
les meilleurs c'est pas dû à Emmanuel
Macron
bon on n'est pas non plus tout à fait
étonné que le figure bien ne trouve pas
beaucoup de qualité Emmanuel Macron mais
quand on regarde l'étude de dance young
bah écoutez on voit bien en tout cas que
la France effectivement aujourd'hui est
devant ses concurrents européens pour le
nombre d'investissements il est pas
exclu que le manuel Macron il soit pour
quelque chose puisque le redressement
vous voyez comment ce tour de 2016 quand
il est arrivé au ministère de l'Économie
mettons quand même un petit bémol
histoire de pas donner complètement tort
à lexicorbières on voit que si le nombre
d'investissement augmente en revanche le
nombre d'emplois lui est en baisse cette
année bon le Parlement le pardon le
Parlement yen le président lui il ne
veut pas se casser l'abattre aujourd'hui
il était de catalysé pour s'adresser à
tout le monde avec un message très clair
accri derrière lui voyez accélérer notre
réindustrialisation parce qu'on a un
point plutôt positif en France c'est que
on ouvre plus d'usine qu'on enferme donc
un solde de 200
usines ouvertes depuis deux ans mais on
voit que ça n'accélère pas au contraire
puisque là avec la crise de l'énergie le
nombre d'ouverture est en baisse alors
comment acc on peut par exemple se
demander aux investisseurs étrangers
quels sont les qualités les défauts de
la France notamment par rapport aux
autres pays donc selon l'étude quand on
parle de nos forces ce qui arrive en
premier mais il y a très largement c'est
l'énergie des carbonées donc celle du
nucléaire c'est extrêmement important
pour les entreprises qui doivent tout
aujourd'hui réduire leur bilan carbone
leurs émissions de CO2 et quand on
demande nos faiblesses et bien c'est le
manque de terrain disponible pour
construire des usines par exemple et
quasiment égalité le manque de
flexibilité de la réglementation
notamment environnementale qui fait que
c'est difficile de s'implanter cela dit
c'est pas un avis complètement tombé du
ciel on a nous-mêmes sorti un rapport en
France l'an dernier de commander par le
gouvernement qui nous disait regardez le
délai théorique pour ouvrir implanter
une usine c'est 9 mois le délai réel
c'est 17 mois c'est-à-dire 4 fois plus
que les Allemands les Polonais donc
évidemment ça demande à être corrigé
donc dès cet après-midi le président a
insisté là-dessus en disant que
désormais pour accélérer il faudrait
réduire par deux ces délais pour implant
on écoute dans le projet de loi
industrie verte nous allons mettre en
place un dispositif une procédure
justement qui va permettre de garantir
un neuf mois entre le moment on dit mon
top l'ensemble des autorisations et le
début des travaux peut se faire au
maximum 9 mois après c'est un élément
clé de compétitivité de réduction des
délais et donc du coup pour un
investisseur alors il a bien sûr annoncé
d'autres mesures pour obtenir cet effet
d'accélération notamment réhabiliter les
friches industrielles pour être prêt à
accueillir des entreprises et aussi des
crédits d'impôts donc vous allez
débattre est-ce que c'est suffisant pas
suffisant j'aurais juste vous rappeler
que les américains avec leur ont
débloqué 400 milliards de dollars de
subventions pour aider à attirer des
usines je sais pas si on sera à la
hauteur peut-être pas la France mais on
fera des comparaisons avec l'Europe tout
à l'heure on poursuit avec vous Marc
l'ermite pour bien comprendre l'état des
lieux déjà sur l'attractivité j'étais
surprise parce que on est on est encore
sur le podium on est champion en 2022
malgré une année compliquée malgré les
grèves malgré Beach qui croit plus qu'on
peut faire des réformes oui d'abord
malgré le contexte économique
international c'est d'abord ça qui en
ont un peu cassé la croissance le retour
de l'économie européenne à parler la
période covid et donc là aussi un peu
freiné en France c'est ça le malgré tout
d'abord c'est un contexte c'est quand
même formidablement compliqué pour les
chefs d'entreprise pour les salariés
pour la population évidemment c'est
c'est ça le contexte
investissement en Europe et moins fort
exactement l'investissement en Europe
est moins fort la France inscrit à peu
près dans la moyenne européenne on voit
les pays d'Europe du Sud les pays
d'Europe centrale les pays d'Europe de
l'Est profitent de la croissance et
c'est tant mieux parce que sont aussi
des pays dans lesquels il y a des
problèmes sociaux des questions
d'emplois qui se posent donc il faut
aussi être un peu européen en même temps
qu'on est français les investisseurs que
vous connaissez
ils sentent que l'environnement
économique a changé vraiment ils sentent
que la France finalement quand on se
regarde de l'extérieur quand on se
compare aux autres on a du mal à croire
de Paris centre on a du mal croire
finalement pratiquement dans tous les
territoires en France et que quand on
nous regarde de l'extérieur la France
c'est pas un miracle il y a tout le
monde est conscient des problèmes des
handicaps assez lourds il y a tellement
de choses à faire dans l'école l'hôpital
etc mais on voit la France finalement
faire un parcours une transformation
assez spectaculaire c'est les chiffres
le disent pas de politique sur ce
plateau et j'en fais d'ailleurs pas du
tout c'est c'est
un peu plus positif que notre marmite
intérieure le coût du travail travail
moins cher principalement les atouts qui
nous voient viennent d'être très bien
rappelés d'ailleurs par Blacko mais je
pense que ce qui ce qu'il faut retenir
en fait c'est que sur l'année 2022
l'année 2023 on a une forme de Constance
une forme de
sérénité mais de résistance de des
entreprises vis-à-vis de la France et
aussi vis-à-vis de l'Europe ça c'est
d'abord la bonne nouvelle les trois ans
qui viennent sont en fait les trois ans
où tout va se jouer la bascule
énergétique la bascule sur la transition
écologique des investissements
technologiques considérables on l'a
entendu à l'Élysée mais on l'entend en
fait tous les jours dans les entreprises
petites moyennes et grandes d'ailleurs
c'est probablement beaucoup plus
difficile pour les petites entreprises
c'est d'elle qu'il fallait s'occuper
aujourd'hui et c'est à elle qu'il
fallait parler aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est ça qui a été fait
les petites entreprises Laurent
Saint-Martin puis je fais circuler
là vous revenez Taïwan je crois oui
enfin j'y étais au courant courant avril
effectivement c'est très important parce
que il y a les microprocesseurs c'était
comment TLMC la grosse entreprise une
grosse entreprise de micro et demain à
Dunkerque une autre entreprise prologium
va installer enfin l'annonce d'une méga
usine de batterie vous le chant vous le
sentez parce que vous vous leur parlez
aux étrangers le regard changer vraiment
le regard se consolider comme la très
bien dit Marc Lhermite ce n'est pas en
2022-2023 que la France est redevenu
attractive ça date de 2016-2017 un
paquet d'attractivité par la fiscalité
par les lois travail par beaucoup
beaucoup de mesures d'attractivité du
quotidien comme on dit à business France
qui ont vraiment changé la donne du
travail il reste quand même plus élevé
européens première étape de flexibilité
a été a été mise en œuvre en 2017 et
elle a été perçue vue et salué en
revanche là où c'est nouveau ce qui
était intéressant pour nous c'est depuis
la crise covid avec la réouverture
notamment en Asie comment la France
est-elle perçue on voit que la France
résiste mieux aux crises que les autres
pays et ça ça a permis encore de
franchir un pas en termes d'attractivité
la France est loin devant le Royaume-Uni
et l'Allemagne en termes de nombre de
projets d'investissement si vous prenez
l'exemple de Taïwan on salue la capacité
à maîtriser l'inflation plus que les
autres pays on salue la capacité sur le
point de vue énergétique à avoir nos
propres forces notamment effectivement
par rapport à l'atome et tout ça
évidemment observer et puis un troisième
facteur qui est très important et qui
est très bien perçu c'est notre
programme d'investissement France 2003
France 2030 c'est investir 54 milliards
d'euros c'est pas le plan de relance
c'est le plan suivant le plan de relance
France 2030 c'est 54 milliards d'euros
dans l'industrie des carbonées mais dans
tous les grands secteurs d'avenir le
quantique les industries culturelles et
créatives le spatial etc etc donc toutes
les grandes entreprises dans le monde
qui veulent investir dans le marché
européen voit le plan France 2030 comme
une terre d'accueil qui leur permet de
prospérer parce que derrière ce sont des
chaînes de valeur qui sont installés et
ces entreprises là derrière évidemment
elles peuvent rester durablement en
France et donc c'est c'est ce triptyque
attractivité par la fiscalité la
réglementation capacité à résister aux
crises plus que les autres pays de quoi
qu'il en coûte a été salué à travers la
planète et puis après la crise notre
capacité de relance et de
réinvestissement dans les grands
secteurs d'avenir et d'innovation c'est
ce package c'est ce tripty qui
aujourd'hui permet à la France de
résister aussi bien Aurélie trouvée
merci Emmanuel Macron en fait bon ça a
été d'abord dit tout à l'heure c'est que
et bien Emmanuel Macron tente de faire
diversion donc en parlant maintenant de
la réindustrialisation comme si il y
avait un miracle de réindustrialisation
je rappelle que c'est pas parce qu'on
attire beaucoup de capitaux étrangers
d'abord que on est capable de maintenir
l'emploi en l'occurrence le bilan
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est un bilan
depuis 10 ans ça fait 10 ans qu'il au
manette n'est pas bon en termes de
réindustrialisation prenant la part vous
comptez quand il était secrétaire
général de l'isée et ministre bien sûr
donc les cinq ans
de l'État depuis 10 ans quel est le
bilan prenons la part de l'emploi
industriel dans l'emploi total et bien
cette part là a encore diminué pendant
ces 10 ans là on est aujourd'hui à 11%
quand on était à peu près 30% en 1970
donc il y a il y a énorme chutes qui n'a
absolument pas été enrayé pendant ces 10
ans là donc il y a pas eu de réponse à
la quand on regarde depuis 2017 les
chiffres ils sont là quand même 100000
emplois créés dans l'industrie 300
créations nettes d'usine 158
relocalisations si on regarde 2017 ça
vous accordez sur ces chiffres d'abord
je pense qu'il faut prendre les
tendances de long terme donc depuis 1970
même si vous prenez là je vous ai parlé
de part de l'emploi industriel dans
l'emploi mais on va parler du long terme
puisque vous dites le nombre d'emplois à
combien on est de nombre d'emplois dans
l'industrie prenons les chiffres les
statistiques on était autour des 5
millions dans les années 70 on est
aujourd'hui autour de 2 millions 6
depuis en fait 2012 il y a eu un mini
rebond
minuscule rebond là depuis quelques
années mais en fait en réalité on le
fait que rattraper et lentement notre
retard et on est un niveau très bas
depuis 2012 qui a 2 millions 600 000
emplois dans l'industrie donc
aujourd'hui et bien il y a pas de
réponse en matière de
réindustrialisation donc la question
elle est qu'est-ce qu'on fait sachant
qu'on est dans un contexte qui est
aujourd'hui très inquiétant puisque on a
notamment une crise de l'énergie des des
des tarifs de l'énergie pour les
entreprises qui augmentent il y a la
fabrique de l'industrie qui dit
attention il y a 117 000 emplois qui
sont qui risquent de disparaître et
regardez le bouclier tarifaire par
exemple l'Allemagne envisage un bouclier
tarifaire à 60 euros du mégawattheure en
France on est je crois à 280 euros du
mégawattheure nous avons la semaine
dernière toute l'opposition dit
maintenant il faut absolument des tarifs
réglementés et plus faibles et donc on
peut faire mieux et beaucoup mieux et
évidemment
on a le ministre Jean-Noël barreau puis
ensuite je vais vers vous filipaillon
parce qu'on a besoin de comprendre la
Big Picture c'est à dire on rattrape un
retard on a tellement détruit avant donc
il faut comprendre pourquoi on en est on
en est que là mais on parle de bons
emplois il a eu ce terme-là le président
de la République on recrée des emplois
mais pas tant que ça dans l'industrie
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à Aurélie
trouver d'abord pas encore établir les
faits la France c'est le pays le plus
attractif en Europe pour la quatrième
année consécutive ce n'était jamais
arrivé avant Emmanuel Macron ensuite
l'emploi industriel baissait depuis des
décennies et depuis 2017 il se remet à
augmenter 100000 emplois créés ça c'est
un fait et ça a commencé après
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron c'est un
million 700 000 emplois qui ont été
créés un chômage qui est au plus bas
depuis 15 ans chômage des jeunes qui est
au plus bas depuis 40 ans mais je crois
qu'il y a une autre question qu'il faut
se poser c'est à qui bénéficie tout ça à
quel territoire bénéficie ces
performances exceptionnelles de l'emploi
industriel et de l'emploi tout court les
investissements étrangers industriels
les investissements étrangers
industriels bénéficient aux trois quarts
aux villes moyennes ces villes même qui
ont été sinistrées par la
désindustrialisation et délaissée par
les gouvernements successifs pendant des
essénies et quant à la baisse du chômage
et à l'augmentation des emplois et
sursaut de l'emploi industriel ce sont
dans l'exemple dans les départements les
plus pauvres de France qu'ils sont
conscients
eh non seulement nous avons libéré avec
Emmanuel Macron l'économie française
mais en plus nous avons fait œuvre de
justice sociale et territoriale en
réparant les dégâts que l'aveuglement
des responsables politiques pendant des
décennies avec laissé sans Ferrer dans
le déclin la phrase grande interview à
nos confrères de challenge aujourd'hui
d'Emmanuel Macron il dit le décrochage
de tente ville moyenne ce sentiment
d'abandon de paupérisation de
déclassement dans la France des
sous-préfectures ces phénomènes sont
intimement liés à cette
désindustrialisation cette bataille est
économique mais aussi
identitaire en gros la France qui a
perdu ses usines elle vote Marine Le Pen
aujourd'hui la France des
sous-préfectures qui a subi plein fouet
la désindustrialisation c'est une France
dans laquelle quand on si quand on s'y
rend on retrouve des friches
industrielles Laurent Saint-Martin
connaît bien ce sujet qui qui témoigne
au quotidien du fait que après la
prospérité le déclin est venu et a
déclasser de manière durable ces
territoires ces usines ces entrepr qui
viennent de France ou d’étranger
reprendre ses friches industrielles
c'est la revanche que ces territoires
prennent sur le déclin et donc c'est
effectivement une question identitaire
en plus d'être une question économique
Philippe à Guillon vous allez nous dire
ce que vous pensez de la politique
industrielle du chef de l'État mais
comprenons d'abord comment on en est
arrivé là les économistes j'en lance
souviens on parle de responsabilités
pendant tout un temps et on a entendu
dire pourquoi pas faire une une société
de service la main d'oeuvre elle est
moins cher ailleurs certes alors c'est
un peu vieux mais la France sans usine
ça a été un discours dans les années 90
est-ce que on a commis une erreur
fondamentale et et qui la commise alors
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
quand il y a eu la crise le covid enfin
la pandémie on manquait de tests de
masques et de respirateur donc on aime
moi je me suis intéressé un peu avec
d'autres collègues on a vu que les
Allemands ils avaient ils avaient tout
ça quoi et nous non et en fait j'ai
regardé dans ces produits là jusqu'au
milieu des années 90 on aussi bon
quasiment que les Allemands et puis
après eux ils ont continué ils sont
devenus des exportateurs nets de 20
milliards par an dans ces produits et
nous on a stagné et en fait j'ai regardé
plein d'autres secteurs pourquoi et en
fait
parler en fait les Allemands ils ont
investi ils ont innové et nous on a
délocalisé alors ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il y a eu le passage à l'euro
avant quand on a des problèmes de
compétitivité on pouvait dévaluer le
franc mais évidemment quand on est passé
à Laurent on pouvait plus d'évaluer et
comme on n'a pas vraiment investi dans
l'innovation et la compétitivité autant
qu'on aurait dû le faire et bien on a
perdu notre compétitivité et nos
entreprises ont délocalisé face aussi au
réglementations 35 heures etc elles ont
dit finalement moi je vais délocaliser
et on voit que dans la plupart des
domaines on était très bon en innovation
l'innovation est un bon prédicteur de
notre état d'avancement dans différents
domaines et on voit que et bien on était
très bons que les années 2000 on
décroche dans quasiment tous les
domaines sauf et bien quelques domaines
et les domaines dans lesquels on
décroche pas c'est le nucléaire
l'aéronautique le luxe et puis
l'isolation thermique les machines
agricoles véhicules autonomes et
quelques domaines et dans le tout le
reste on décroche on décroche
économiques de politique économique ou
ce sont les entreprises elles-mêmes qui
voient que la main d'oeuvre est en moins
cher font leur propre choix parce que on
n'a pas vu l'importance de d'être une
économie compétitive qu'il faut un
environnement d'abord qui soit favorable
à l'entreprise qui soit fiscale et
réglementaire favorable et également qui
est important d'avoir des politiques
industrielles donc c'est à la fois ce
que j'appelle des politiques
horizontales
politiques d'éducation d'innovation de
recherche fondamentale capitale risque
investisseur institutionnel fiscalité
donc tout ça c'est horizontal ça
concerne toutes les entreprises et tous
les secteurs et également on n'a pas vu
qu'il y avait des secteurs de vous
importants où on décrochait et qu'il
fallait que on ait une politique alors
c'est en partie la faute de la France
mais je dois dire que l'Europe ne nous a
pas beaucoup aidé on viendra peut-être
tout à l'heure il faut changer en tout
cas la manière dont on pratique les
institutions européennes les aides
publiques la politique de la concurrence
il suffit pas simplement de faire
davantage de réforme structurelles il
faut que l'Europe se mette en marche
industrielle face aux États-Unis à la
Chine mais peut-être qu'on reviendra sur
ce débat on se déliant peut-être les
mains par rapport à certaines règles et
certaines contraintes bon le tableau il
est plutôt positif il est pas parfait
parce qu'on rattrape un retard et un
loup retard par rapport à nos voisins
qui ont des PME
je vais vous montrer quand même une les
images d'une usine parce que c'est dans
le Nord où il sera le président demain
valdune 350 salariés à menacés dans
cette usine qui fabrique cette
industries c'est des essieux des roues
dans le ferroviaire écoutez les salariés
il se relais depuis 6 jours pour
défendre leur usine
et alimenter le feu de la colère jeudi
dernier ils ont appris le désengagement
de leur actionnaire chinois disant après
avoir repris ce fleuron de l'industrie
ferroviaire un coup dur pour les 350
salariés des deux usines Nordistes quand
on arrive jaune embaucher on se dit
voilà c'est l'avenir le ferroviaire
alors on s'aperçoit que même la seule
usine française qui reste aujourd'hui on
arrive quasi à dépôt de bilan c'est un
sentiment
dégoût parce que bon on est quand même
une sacrée entreprise en France on avait
seul à faire les routes train et sûr
plus des galets et aujourd'hui on nous
abandonne
qu'est-ce que vous répondez Jean-Noël
barreau parce que c'est voilà il y a des
repreneurs c'est pas sûr c'est de
l'emploi qui est en jeu la volonté
politique aujourd'hui quand il y a une
concurrence une difficulté c'est d'aller
défendre jusqu'au bout le dernier emploi
bien sûr et c'est ce que fait Bruno Le
Maire et c'est ce que fait Roland
Lescure qui se mobilise avec autant
d'énergie lorsque des sites sont menacés
que lorsqu'il s'agit d'attirer des sites
industriels nouveaux dans notre pays ou
de de soutenir le développement en
France de site industriels qu'ils soient
qu'ils émanent d'entreprises françaises
ou de établir ou de
Roland Lescure les a les a entendus et
s'y est rendu à plusieurs reprises et
qui met toute son énergie pour essayer
de trouver des solutions alors je
voudrais qu'on revienne avant de voir si
il faut aller jusqu'à des règles qui
ressemblent à du protectionnisme même si
évidemment pas prononcé le mot à nos à
nos avantages comparatifs Marc Lamy
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que on doit
faire dans quel secteur on entend parler
du spat du quantique évidemment du
numérique l'intelligence artificielle si
on avait les moyens d'avoir voilà les
moyens américains dans quoi il faudrait
investir le France 2030 trace 8 grands
secteurs et c'est franchement donne une
vision qui est assez claire qui est
assez simple Laurent Saint-Martin l'a
dit c'est ça va de l'industrie très
lourde l'hydrogène la mobilité
électrique on dit aussi la culture les
industries créatives il y a toutes les
variétés de secteurs en France et la
France qu'une très grande économie
deuxième économie européenne c'est
d'abord ça qui attire les entreprises
d'ailleurs c'est ça qui réattire les
entreprises donc c'est probablement dans
l'ensemble de ces secteurs là en étant
certains et conscients des atouts que
nous renvoie les enquêtes qu'on mène
notamment un atout formidable en ce
moment qui est celui de la disponibilité
d’énergie des carbonée ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure il faut savoir que c'est
le plus gros handicap de l'Allemagne
aujourd'hui l'Allemagne qu'on a envie
pour son capacité exportatrice des
leaders mondiaux et par exemple moi
cette entreprise me fascine parce qu'on
comprend que
sans eux tout s'arrête nos smartphones
nos télésta ils sont à Taïwan Biden les
a fait venir aux États-Unis apparemment
c'est l'Allemagne qui aurait une
usine TSMC adresse là on a perdu ce
marché c'est très important ce concentre
sur les très gros projets alors la
France heureusement dans les batteries
notamment a réussi en en attrapé en
attirer quelques-uns pardon mais
l'Allemagne qui a un pays de plein
emploi qui a donc c'est un problème pour
les nouveaux investisseurs qui veulent
recruter très rapidement des centaines
de d'emplois se concentrent notamment
dans l'ex Allemagne de l'Est sur les
gigafactory les très très gros projet
Tesla Intel TSMC etc et c'est à peu près
tout et c'est notamment pour les trois
cinq années qui viennent à peu près tout
ce qu'ils pourront faire parce que les
mêmes industriels dans ces secteurs et
dans d'autres disent nous le fait que
l'Allemagne arrête le nucléaire n'aille
pas très vite sur la sont des marchés
renouvelables ouvre une gigantesque
cuisine qui se produit qui produit au
charbon c'est un gros problème pour nous
entreprises dans notre propre objectif
de décan les Allemands ne nous dames pas
le pion au contraire nous prenons
toujours plus d'avant depuis ces
dernières années avec avec l'Allemagne
il est aussi intéressant de noter que
l'Allemagne soit le premier soit le
deuxième pays qui investit en France ça
aussi c'est de donner c'est des données
intéressantes vous dites que par exemple
cette cette grande industrie taïwanaise
choisir l'Allemagne c'est pas sûr encore
évidemment que l'Allemagne continue
vous avez cité prologium à Dunkerque
demain c'est les vrais par le Président
de la République 5 milliards d'euros
plus 3000 emplois ce sont des projets
que nous n'aurions jamais eu encore
quelques années comment est-ce qu'on a
fait en sorte que la France puisse
attirer c'est gigafactory c'est très
gros projet que justement l'Allemagne
trust et un petit peu en Europe pas que
avec le Royaume-Uni notamment parce que
la France est aussi professionnalisée
dans la capacité à tirer les
investissements on en parle trop peu
c'est le travail de business France ça
typiquement comment est-ce qu'on fait en
sorte d'avoir des sites industriels clés
en main prête à l'emploi le délai qu'on
réduit chaque année et il faut
effectivement atteindre 9 mois qui
vraiment l'objectif pour pouvoir être
encore plus compétitif comment est-ce
qu'on fait en sorte que l'État et les
collectivités territoriales en sommes
maintenant la main puisse attirer ses
projets internationaux on a fait des
progrès considérables ces dernières
années là-dessus avant quand il fallait
investir en France il y avait lourdeur
fiscal lourdeur administrative
incapacité entre l'État et les
collectivités à se mettre d'accord et le
projet était déjà parti en Allemagne ce
qui a vraiment vraiment changé ces
dernières années c'est cette capacité à
capter les gros projets aussi par notre
capacité foncière à la mettre en avant
raccourcir des délais à peu près deux
ans pour s'implanter dans en usine en
France c'est trop long ça c'est des
délais c'est la procédure simplifiée
accélérer vous vous pouvez être d'accord
là-dessus le problème n'est pas là et je
voudrais d'abord revenir sur le je vais
revenir d'abord sur le tableau idyllique
que vous brossez de la France c'est
normal c'est votre job mais enfin
aujourd'hui regardez l'usine valdune
pourtant on parle d'industrie verte
voilà une usine qui fabrique des roues
de train et qui risque de fermer mais la
France est aussi de très nombreuses
fermetures d'usines de fonderie de
textile d'électroménager et j'en passe
et il y a vous parlez de création
d'usine mais il y a aussi beaucoup de
destruction d'usine et notamment sur des
secteurs qui sont les secteurs de la
bifurcation
j'en arrive au problème justement
aujourd'hui ce que font d'autres pays
c'est un de cibler leur soutien le
cibler sur des entreprises et des aides
qui d'abord font d'habitude or il y a
des milliards qui ont été déversés aux
entreprises sans condition écologiques
et sans condition sociale donc il faut
absolument aujourd'hui conditionner sur
plan écologique et social ces aides et
ça n'est pas prévu dans le projet de loi
sur les industries vertes et c'est un
vrai problème il faut aussi une vraie il
faut une vraie
il faut une vraie écouter le plan de
relance 100 milliards d'euros quasiment
aucune condition écologique et
aujourd'hui le projet de loi sur les
industrielles vous l'avez lu déjà et
surtout et on a le premier projet
et surtout dans le projet de loi sur les
industries vertes manque un soutien
conséquent quand on voit l'argent qui
est mis sur la table il était question
des 400 milliards aux États-Unis
l'argent qui est mis sur la table par
d'autres pays aujourd'hui je crois que
c'est 700 millions d'euros que vous
proposez dans le projet de loi
industriel
formation seulement voilà mais donc on
attend les autres chiffres mais voilà ce
qu'il faut c'est aussi un soutien très
conséquent mais ciblé cibler sur les TPE
et PME le problème c'est que depuis 10
ans depuis les six ans d'Emmanuel Macron
au pouvoir il y a eu d'énormes
réductions d'impôts qui ont qui ont été
bien trop possible et qui ont beaucoup
bénéficié au très grandes entreprises la
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée qui
était supprimée qui coûte des milliards
d'euros par an
attractivité essentiellement ça
bénéficie essentiellement au grandes
entreprises plusieurs économies études
économiques le montrent donc cibler les
TPE PME cibler les entreprises qui
maintiennent l'emploi qui évidemment
aussi font de l'emploi de qualité alors
et puis je finis sur la c'est le débat
quelque part du premier quinquennat mais
il est toujours d'actualité pour vous le
président a bien dit que pour lui toute
la contrainte entre guillemets
environnementale ne devrait pas freiner
la reconquête industrielle et il pense
même que au contraire ça irait plus vite
je vais vous donner un exemple bonus
électrique c'est un nouveau moyen de
faire le tri entre les voitures
électriques fabriquées en Chine et celle
fabriquées en France est-ce que c'est du
protectionnisme explication avec Marco
pommier
le bonus écologique français une aide à
l'achat pour les véhicules électriques
aujourd'hui l'aide financière s'applique
à n'importe quel modèle qu'il soit
fabriqué en France aux États-Unis ou en
Chine une hérésie pour Emmanuel Macron
on va soutenir les batteries
et les véhicules qui sont produits en
Europe parce que leur empreinte carbone
est bonne et on va pas mettre ces bonus
ça veut pas dire qu'on fait du
protectionnisme on va pas fermé le
marché mais on va pas utiliser l'argent
du contribuable français pour accélérer
l'industrialisation non européenne en
clair le bonus écologique français qui
peut atteindre jusqu'à 7000 euros selon
les revenus sera attribué en fonction de
l'empreinte carbone du véhicule
électrique lors de sa production au-delà
d'un certain seuil aucune subvention de
quoi exclure d'emblée les modèles
fabriqués en Chine et en Corée du Sud
objectif
avantager le marché européen ou
quasiment l'ensemble des voitures et
compris sont conçus avec de
l’électricité des carbonées une mesure
attendue par les constructeurs français
mais un stratagème anticipé par la firme
américaine Tesla dont le modèle y est
devenu le modèle électrique le plus
vendu en France au premier trimestre
2023 Tesla c'est prémuni en quelque
sorte contre ce danger là en assemblant
ses véhicules dans l'usine de Berlin qui
est destiné à être ça sa troisième plus
grosse usine après celle des Etats-Unis
et celle de Chine Emmanuel Macron
s'inspire du modèle américain aux
États-Unis le plan climat de Joe Biden
prévoit jusqu'à 7500 dollars de crédit
d'impôt pour l'achat d'un véhicule
électrique à l'exception de ce produit
en Chine
Philippe haguillon ça va dans le bon
sens on ouvre enfin les yeux ou pas
selon vous oui il faut pas être naïf le
l'Iran in flation reduction actes donc
c'est 737 milliards de dollars sur 10
ans 370 milliards de dollars en
subvention crédit d'impôt et
effectivement un américain reçoit 7500
dollars de crédit d'impôt si il achète
un véhicule assemblé aux États-Unis dans
les batteries reposent pour au moins 40%
sur des composants américains donc un
truc comme ça tu dis je peux pas
simplement dire j'approfondis les
réformes structurelles quoi donc comme
la doxa européenne on a une Europe trop
haïkienne il faut changer
beaucoup de choses mais il pensait qu'il
fallait le surtout le laisser faire
comme il fallait laisser le marché je
crois beaucoup dans les vertus du marché
mais je crois aussi dans les vertus de
l'État et je crois dans les vertus de la
société civile et je crois beaucoup dans
le triangle marcher est associé civile
Hayek pour lui il y avait que le marché
et pas besoin d’état pas besoin de
société civile donc là je suis
totalement et il fallait vraiment que le
désaccord avec beaucoup de
réglementations et peut c'est vraiment
l'Europe qui est géant réglementaire
nain budgétaire et il faut sortir de
l'Europe géant réglementaire et d'un
budgétaire et alors comment on peut
faire ça donc il y avait différents
outils d'abord il y a Maastricht il y a
le déficit on disait voilà il faut pas
que le déficit dépasse 3 % du Pipe peu
importe où vont les dépenses embêter sur
le même plan les dépenses récurrentes et
ça fonctionnement de l'État traite etc
et les dépenses d'investissement moi je
pense qu'il faut pas les compter de la
même manière
il faut prendre en compte quand on fait
une dépense que c'est une dépense pour
la croissance et la transition
énergétique ou pas et pas le compter de
la même manière donc déjà ça c'est la
première chose deuxièmement on a une
politique de concurrence en Europe au
nom de laquelle on interdit tout aide
sectorielle d'État tout est sectoriel
d'État on dit ah non non ça va pas ça va
contre la concurrence et ça il faut que
ça change il faut autoriser les aides
sectorielles d'État puis après regarder
non français
la concurrence et s'il y a eu réduction
de la concurrence et bien à ce moment-là
on demande et bien s'il y a des fusions
acquisition par exemple qui conduisent à
des vraiment empêcher l'entrée de
nouveaux innovants etc bah à ce
moment-là on régule mais a priori on n'a
pas cette a priori donc on se délier les
mains et le troisième chose c'est que
les Européens c'est 1% du PIB et
l'Europe n'a pratiquement jamais
emprunté jusqu'à par la pandémie et il
faut que l'Europe qu'on augmente le
budget européen et qu'on autorise
l'Europe à emprunter en temps
parce qu'on est face à la Chine aux
États-Unis et on voit vraiment les
courbes de l'innovation la Chine et les
admis sont très haut et nous on tombe
donc on devient comme les Japonais donc
il faut vraiment inverser ça et donc
c'est pas qu'il faut totalement changer
d'institution européenne il faut
pratiquer différemment les outils
européens
sans changer les traités parce que la
politique des aides et la différence il
faut les interpréter les pratiquer
différentes Jean-Noël Barrault c'est
fondamental ce que vient de dire
Philippe Aguillon est-ce que il y a une
volonté politique pour les inter ont été
différemment et pour ce sarmer
véritablement face aux États-Unis à la
Chine la preuve vous avez entendu le
président de la République
aujourd'hui une mesure qui qui répond en
quelque sorte à
l'élan donnée par ira aux États-Unis en
conditionnant le bonus écologique au
fait que le véhicule électrique soit
conçu en France
de Philippe Paillot au niveau européen
mais je veux dire là on a une mesure
très concrète qui dit que les aides de
public elles ne viendront que pour les
batteries qui seront conçus en France
par exemple pour vous je pense
d'ailleurs que ça devait enfin plus
largement et on portera d'ailleurs dans
nos amendements il faudrait que les par
exemple dans les marchés publics il y a
une inconditionnement au local beaucoup
plus important bon ça demande quand même
justement de ne plus être dans une
vision du néolibéralisme économique la
vision alliés dont vous parlez dans une
vision keynésienne qui dit en fait le
marché ne peut pas tout il faut une
forte régulation de l'État et ça c'est
contraire je suis désolé de le dire mais
c'est quoi
on en a beaucoup des régulations
de marché parce que quand par exemple
vous conditionnez au local vous
conditionnez sur le plan écologique et
social vous faites de la régulation et
il en faut en fait le marché le laisser
faire et bien ça ne marche pas et ça
conduit en tout cas il y a des
passerelles alors il y a des divergences
mais il y a aussi des points d'accord
c'est intéressant rapidement parce que
sur la pardon sur l'histoire des
voitures électriques parce que c'est
intéressant vous voyez la dame qu'est-ce
qu'elle dit elle dit si on veut vraiment
des voitures écologiques et si on veut
qu'il y a une efficacité écologique à
cela il faut surtout agir sur la taille
des véhicules et la taille des batteries
or par exemple ça n'est pas du tout dans
le projet de loi industrie verte alors
croyez-moi il arrive à l'Assemblée on
verra ce que vous amendez ou pas c'est
la fin le mot de la fin rapidement juste
rappeler pour business a été initié
avant l'irra comme quoi la France et
l'Europe peuvent aussi avoir des par
rapport à ces problématiques là sinon je
suis tout à fait d'accord si on continue
à s'embêter nous-mêmes pour être poli en
Europe effectivement sur la régulation
je crois qu'on a déjà nous-mêmes nos
capacités à nous mettre nos propres
francs qu'il faudrait savoir lever sur
ce plateau c'est un sujet de
souveraineté fondamentale l'industrie
merci on s'arrête là merci infiniment
d'être venu débattre vous restez avec
moi Jean-Noël barreau dans une petite
dizaine de minutes les parties pris de
nos affranchis pour vous interpeller
monsieur le ministre ce soir le
philosophe Pierre-Henri tavoyau qui va
remonter aux origines du débat sur
l'immigration Delphine Sabatier qui va
nous raconter comment Google
contre-attaque check jeepetty et puis
dans Bourbon Express ce soir elles amont
d'agaba nous raconte ce maire menacé qui
finit par démissionner mais d'abord on
va se pencher sur votre parcours mais
surtout sur votre projet de loi sécurisé
et réguler l'espace numérique c'est un
défi de taille vous vous y appelez avec
des mesures très très concrètes on voit
cela dans le détail dans l'invitation
d'Hélène Bonduelle et on en parle
ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Jean-Noël barreau
c'est pour éviter les arnaques sur
internet ou encore se prémunir des
cyberattaques c'est en tout cas votre
ambition Jean-Noël Barrault vous êtes
économiste de formation et vous exercez
comme enseignant chercheurs puis c'est
une histoire de famille comme votre père
Jacques et votre grand-père résistant
Noël vous devenez député avant de vous
voir confier l'été dernier le poste de
ministre chargé de la transition
numérique et des télés communication
avec donc ce nouveau projet de loi
sécurisé réguler l'espace numérique bref
vous entendez faire respecter l'ordre
public en ligne 18 millions de Français
ont été victimes de cyberatta que
l'année dernière et la moitié ont perdu
de l'argent au passage notamment à cause
de ces mails ou ses SMS frauduleux qui
redirige vers des sites de hacker
je me suis dit bon c'est bizarre un
numéro de portable voilà c'était un peu
troublant vous proposez un filtre anti
arnaque pour couper le mâle à la racine
en dévitalisant le commerce de ces
pirates 100 fois ni loi qui ont fait de
nos smartphones nos téléphones portables
qu'on a dans la poche l'instrument de
leur raquette dans votre projet de loi
vous voulez aussi lutter contre le
cyber-harcèlement punir plus sévèrement
ces chefs demeutes numériques en les
bannissant des réseaux sociaux
lorsqu'ils ont été condamnés
pour protéger les mineurs de la
pornographie vous vous attaquez au site
a contenu sexuel qui ne vérifie pas
l'âge du visiteur et vous proposez que
ce soit l'arcom qui s'en charge
l'Autorité de régulation pourrait ainsi
bloquer ces sites pornographiques sans
passer par un juge ces derniers temps
plusieurs institutions ont été piratées
les sites de l'Assemblée nationale du
Sénat de nombreux hôpitaux ont aussi été
prises aux mains des hackers c'est une
attaque massive exceptionnelle par son
ampleur et surtout par ses conséquences
vous voulez faire du numérique un espace
de confiance mais alors Jean-Noël
Barrault comment lutter efficacement
contre ses attaques informatiques à
répétition face à des hacker qui ont
toujours un coup d'avance
réponse monsieur le ministre c'est pas
un peu de David contre Goliath ce combat
non je crois qu'il est à portée de
demain je crois que déjà depuis six ans
beaucoup de choses ont été faites au
niveau national au niveau européen ou la
France a fait adopter l'année dernière
des règles très importantes qui vont
s'appliquer dans l'ensemble des États
membres de l'Union européenne et qui
s'imposeront aux géant du numérique si
il souhaite entrer sur le plus grand
marché économique du monde qui est le
marché européen d'ailleurs cette loi
c'est la transposition en partie de ces
directives digitales market actes et
digital services actes décidez à 27 sur
la cybersécurité entière arnaque donc il
y a un filtre que vous voulez mettre en
place ce sont les particuliers qui vont
devoir jouer le jeu en signalant les
arnaques ou les soupçons d'arnaque dont
ils font l'objet est-ce que ça sera
suffisant vous pensez qu'ils seront au
rendez-vous le filtre anti ternacle
c'était un engagement présidentiel
d'Emmanuel Macron lors de la campagne
présidentielle pour 2022
c'est un rempart
contre les campagnes de SMS et de mails
frauduleux que nous avons toutes et tous
subis tout le monde a reçu un sms du
compte personnel de formation de la Sécu
claire fois de la borne
ce filtre anti-arnaque il filtrera
préventivement le site identifiés comme
étant malveillant il coupera le mal à
large établi à la racine qui sera
alimentée dès que une personne est
victime et qu'elle notifie le site
internet en question bien cette liste
sera actualisée et tous les Français
seront protégés le cyber-harcèlement là
encore on ne compte plus les victimes et
principalement les mineurs comment ça va
se passer avec les harceleurs parce
qu'il y a une forme d'impunité est-ce
que vous pensez que on va réussir à ce
qu'il sait son coup pour leur compte en
les bannissant d'Internet tout ça c'est
efficace on peut toujours recréer un
compte un nouvel un nouveau pseudo
principalement les mineurs et
principalement des femmes et à tous les
âges de la vie et le cyber-harcèlement
c'est une violence qu'on voit d'ailleurs
se déplacer d'un réseau social à l'autre
et parfois jusque dans l'espace physique
où on voit des agressions tragiques et
tout ça c'est le fait d'une minorité
d'internautes qui se comporte comme des
chefs de meute qui propagent la haine et
la violence qui embrasse leur communauté
et qui déclenchent des raids ciblées sur
les personnes qui veulent agresser donc
il faut mettre fin à cette impunité
comment concrètement d'impunité ce que
nous proposons c'est très long mais il
faut néanmoins que certaines peines
exemplaires puissent être prononcées ça
a été le cas dans l'affaire Mila ça a
été le cas dans l'affaire et des Pretto
ce que nous proposons en plus de la
peine qui cible ses agresseurs et bien
c'est une peine complémentaire de
bannissement à l'image de l'interdiction
des stades pour les hooligans qui sont
condamnés et que le juge prononçait à
leur rencontre pendant six mois ils
auront l'interdiction de se réinscrire
sur un réseau social ou plus précisément
le réseau social devra mettre tous les
moyens en œuvre pour empêcher leur
réinscription et cette peine sera portée
à un an de bannissement dans cette
affaire c'est les Gafa qui sont les
premières responsables en tout cas les
premières vigiles les grandes
plateformes est-ce que vous trouvez
qu'elle joue le jeu parce que cette
réglementation européenne même s'il faut
la transposer dans les différents pays
elle est entre en vigueur est-ce qu'on
voit déjà leur comportement changé dans
la régulation notamment on l'a vu un peu
depuis quelques années et notamment
parce que la France avec la loi valeur
de la République adoptée il y a deux ans
imposé avant que le règlement ne soit
adopté des obligations de vigilance de
modération des contenus illicites qui
leur sont signés mais désormais c'est
une obligation qui leur sera faite au
niveau européen de retirer les contenus
qui leur sont signalés de d'analyser le
risque qu'elles font peser sur leurs
utilisateurs et on débat public sinon
des sanctions qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
6% du chiffre d'affaires pour Twitter
c'est 300 millions d'euros environ et
oui elle ne met pas en place des actions
de correction ça peut aller jusqu'à
l'interdiction d'opérer sur le
territoire
a racheté Twitter et la manière dont il
conçoit son réseau social
l'usage de la liberté d'expression vous
croyez qu'on peut lui faire confiance et
qu'on peut lui appliquer ce type de loi
de savoir ce que je crois ou ce que je
ne crois pas il sera vraiment
s'il ne les respecte pas c'est 6 % du
chiffre d'affaires la première fois et
c'est l'interdiction de Twitter en
Europe la seconde concernant la
pornographie alors là vous mettez en
place un contrôle d'âge des utilisateurs
des plateformes c'est une forme de
vérification de la majorité numérique
grâce à un tiers de confiance qui doit
contacter la plateforme pour garantir ou
doublement vérifier que la personne qui
utilise ce site est bien majeur c'est
qui ce tiers de confiance c'est la
banque c'est l'assurance maladie c'est
qui alors d'abord il faut rappeler qu'il
y a 2 millions d'enfants chaque mois
dans notre pays qui sont exposés à des
contenus pornographiques pourquoi parce
pense que les sites concernés ne
vérifient pas l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs alors qu'ils y sont tenus
par la loi il y a même une procédure
judiciaire qui est en cours le verdict
sera rendu au mois de juillet et
j'espère qu'il sera exemplaire des
solutions techniques existent pour
vérifier l'âge les utilisateurs elles
existent elles sont sur le marché elles
existent depuis longtemps donc les sites
n'ont aucune excuse mais en parallèle
j'ai fait appel ou en tout cas j'ai
lancé un appel à ce que des entreprises
françaises développent des systèmes de
vérification d'âge qui soit à la fois
fiable et respectueux de la vie privée
pour que un site qui doit mettre une en
place une vérification d'âge puisse
aussi mettre en place une vérification
d'âge qui reste anonyme
le projet de loi c'est c'est pour
l'avenir de nous permettre d'agir
beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup plus vite
en confiant à l’arcome qui est
l'autorité de contrôle des
communications et d'Internet le pouvoir
de bloquer et de des référencer sur les
moteurs de recherche un site
pornographiques qui ne vérifiera pas
l'âge de ses utilisateurs combien de
divisions j'ai envie de vous lire
suffisamment d'agents il y a déjà
beaucoup de missions ils vont avoir les
moyens de faire ce travail de contrôle
le blocage pour intervenir en quelques
semaines seulement l'arcome est une
autorité centrale dans l'application des
textes européens qui s'imposeront aux
géant du numérique qu'on évoquait à
l'instant et et la recom est déjà une
une autorité que à qui la loi a confié
le soin de vérifier que les sites font
bien respecter l'interdiction
d'exposition des mineurs aussi de
pornographiques avec cette mesure ils
pourront simplement aller directement à
la mesure de blocage en quelques
secondes plus larges très rapidement
comment vous regardez l'intelligence
artificielle vous avez évidemment vu le
New York Times le fondateur de l'IA qui
parle de cauchemars Biden qui réunit les
géants de l'intelligence artificielle en
réfléchissant déjà aux limites aux
problèmes éthiques que ça pose elle est
où la volonté ou le débat en France sur
ces sujets fondamentaux l'intelligence
artificielle en général ça fait
longtemps qu'on l'a invité dans notre
quotidien et elle nous permet chaque
jour de mieux nous déplacer de mieux
nous informer de mieux nous soigner
d'ailleurs puisque on estime que dans
quelques années c'est un tiers des
médicaments qui sera découvert grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle mais aussi
danger la nouveauté c'est l'intelligence
artificielle générative qui elle aussi
avec chat GPT et autres est une est une
évolution très intéressante pourquoi
parce qu'elle nous permettra lorsqu'elle
sera fiabilisée lorsqu'elle aura trouvé
son rythme de croisière d'accéder au
patrimoine informationnel au patrimoine
de connaissances de l'humanité de
manière simple et ça c'est évidemment un
avantage majeur donc c'est pour la
distribution oui mais il était
indispensable d'abord que la France
puisse maîtriser cette technologie
d'abord parce qu'on en a les besoins on
en a pardon les moyens les Français sont
les meilleurs en intelligence
artificielle et on les retrouve dans
tous les laboratoires d'intelligence
artificielle privée comme public ensuite
parce que c'est une technologie de la
représentation on accumule ou on
compacte la connaissance et on l'a
retranscrit c'est une technologie de la
représentation et donc il est impensable
que nous puissions nous appuyer en
France sur des logiciels qui ne sur
lesquels on n'aurait pas imprimé notre
vision de l'homme et de l'humanité et
enfin parce que c'est une question de
souveraineté on va pas laisser cesser on
va pas emprunter les outils conçus par
des entreprises privées issues de
journées
une dernière question je ne résiste pas
il nous reste une poignée de secondes
vous avez forcément lu le point la
grande interview de Laurent Wauquiez
avec qui voilà vous avez certaines
relations parce que une histoire commune
il a il a longtemps travaillé avec votre
père Jacques barreau qu'est-ce que vous
en avez pensé certains éditorialistes
parlent d'un Trump à la française j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait un certain nombre
de
de compliments ou de presque compliment
à l'égard de la majorité et du président
de la République et vous savez moi je
crois que ce qui est important en
politique c'est la constance leur avocat
a commencé au centre il est ensuite allé
un peu plus à droite après un peu plus
encore à droite puis la disparu un peu
des écrans il revient avec des
propositions beaucoup plus centristes
qui sait où il va terminer on suivra ça
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite installez-vous Delphine
Sabatier pour l'oeil sur le numérique ça
va vous intéresser monsieur le ministre
Pierre-Henri tavoyau qui préside le
collège de philosophie bonsoir à vous
les amis on commence avec le bourbon
Express ou pas de charge le temps nous
décompter présenter ce soir par Elsa
monde un gaval histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vais
vous raconter l'histoire d'un maire qui
vient démissionner ce maire c'est
Yannick Morez mère d'hiver droite de
Saint-Brevin une ville de 15000
habitants en Loire-Atlantique là il pose
devant son domicile ciblé par un
incendie volontaire sa ville elle est
depuis quelques mois le théâtre de
manifestation pro et anti cada les cadas
ce sont ces centres d'accueil pour
demandeurs d'asile chez les Antilles
c'est souvent l'extrême droite qui est à
la manœuvre et on l'a vu les lieux a été
victime d'intimidation de menaces de
mort et donc le 22 mars dernier sa
maison a été incendiée hier soir il
annonce qu'il démissionne qu'il déménage
dans l'hémicycle député Jérôme Guedj lui
rend hommage tous les députés se
joignent à cet hommage enfin presque
regarder et écouter
victime lui de ce qu'il qualifie être un
terrorisme d'extrême droite puisque son
domicile a été incendié parce qu'il
défendait l'installation d'un centre
d'accueil et de demandeurs d'asile et
donc des événements de cette nature
nous interpellent
on a constaté à ce moment-là que les
députés du rasement national sont
laissés sont restés totalement assis ça
me fait penser à un proverbe de ma
grand-mère celui qui se sent morveux se
mouche alors évidemment ce matin avec
Steven Martin on était salle des quêtes
colonnes on cherchait à interroger des
députés du rassemblement national pour
leur poser la question pourquoi les
députés du rassemblement national ne se
sont pas levés après l'hommage au maire
de Saint-Brévin pour une raison simple
afin de parler encore avec mes collègues
ce matin c'est qu'il y a eu un Brouard
et en fait de nos bandes rien entendu de
ce que disait monsieur Guedj certains
ont d'autres interprétations sur le fait
que des députés de votre groupe ne se
soient pas levé il dit c'est parce que
finalement vous êtes mal à l'aise
puisque c'est l'extrême droite qui a
organisé des manifestations dans cette
ville et qui a poussé ce maire aussi à
la démission mais c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi nous ne sommes jamais
associés à ces manifestations nous avons
systématiquement dénoncé toute forme de
violence de pression sur les élus se
maire démissionne je suis désolé j'ai
encore relu ces déclarations parce qu'il
a été abandonné
par l'État abandonné par ceux qui sont
responsabilités c'est vrai que dans le
communiqué où il annonce sa décision
publiée sur Facebook le maire de
Saint-Brevin dénonce le manque de
soutien de l'État et ce matin la
première ministre et le chef de l'État
ont réagi oui Emmanuel Macron dans un
tweet à regretter la démission du maire
regardez les attaques contre Yannick
Morez maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins et
contre sa famille sont indignes à cette
élu de la République à son épouse et à
ses enfants je redis ma solidarité et à
celle de la nation depuis la réunion la
première ministre à elle aussi dénoncée
elle a promis de mieux protéger les élus
mais elle est un peu renvoyée les
extrémismes des deux côtés cette
expression elle n'a pas du tout plu à
Fabien Roussel le chef du parti
communiste
j'aimerais bien que le gouvernement au
lieu de parler des extrêmes qualifie ces
agressions et là on parle d'extrême
droite clairement vous faites référence
ce matin la déclaration de la première
ministre qui a dénoncé une montée des
extrêmes des deux côtés oui parce que
mal nommé les choses et bien c'est mal
réglé derrière la semaine prochaine le
gouvernement va dévoiler des mesures
pour lutter plus efficacement contre les
violences à l'égard des élus c'est vrai
que dans les villes où il y a des
centres d'accueil de réfugiés qui
doivent être installés souvent les aides
sont la cible de menace venue de
l'extrême droite merci beaucoup Elsa on
enchaîne avec vous Pierre-Henri tavoyau
débat sur l'immigration qui revient le
gouvernement qui tergiverse j'y vais j'y
vais pas bon vous souhaitiez-vous
revenir sur un débat bien français oui
parce qu'en fait depuis 1980 il y a eu
29 lois sur l'immigration ça fait une
loi toutes les 17 mois donc c'est quand
même beaucoup et on s'aperçoit que c'est
une accumulation de mesure qui sont
assez largement contradictoires
dans un ancien sénateur buffet disait
qu'au fond notre système de politique
migratoire était assez maltraitant avec
les migrants légaux et à cette
bienfaisant avec les migrants illégaux
donc on a un truc complètement absurde
et c'est vraiment le problème en France
de cette nature du débat alors pour vous
cette situation et moi une cause qu'une
conséquence c'est ça de quoi en fait la
formule peut paraître un peu étonnante
mais je pense que le débat en France sur
l'immigration n'est pas un débat
politique c'est un débat philosophique
et moral c'est pas un débat politique si
on essaie de formuler la question
politique elle est en fait très simple
et se présente sous la forme d'un
dilemme l'immigration est à la fois
nécessaire pour la puissance française
et en même temps dangereuse pour la
cohésion sociale voilà le problème c'est
ça le problème c'est les deux en même
temps c'est ce dilemme et c'est ce
point-là qu'on a totalement oublié au
profit d'autres thématiques alors
justement il est où le débat pour vous
en fait il situe dans une sorte de
d'affrontement entre deux grandes thèses
qui s'affrontent d'un côté le grand
méchant remplacement de l'autre côté la
jolie gentille créol voilà on a les deux
thèses qui se présentent de cette
manière tous deux des toutes les deux
thèses défendent l'idée qu'il y a un
ethnocide en cours un ethnocide soit de
la population française par la
mondialisation soit des minorités
opprimées par l'assimilation
toutes les deux thèses considèrent
qu'effectivement il y a des réalités
historiques c'est-à-dire il y a eu des
grands remplacements dans l'histoire par
exemple le premier dit-on c'est
Néandertal par le sapiens c'était le
premier grand remplacement du côté de la
créolité et oui c'est un fait la
créativité ça existe aux Antilles au
Brésil à la Réunion donc c'est un fait
deuxièmement toutes les deux s'appuie
également sur des auteurs des
théoriciens bien connu donc Renaud Camus
pour le grand remplacement qui est parti
par deux de détestations pas détestation
simplement des populations invasives si
je puis dire mais détestation aussi des
élites mondialisées qui aident et qui
favorise ce grand remplacement puis du
côté de la créalisation un grand poète
et philosophe qui s'appelle Edward
Glisson qui est le grand penseur qui
considère que la créolité c'est pas
simplement
identité c'est un processus complexe une
alchimie où on la différence produit de
l'identité l'identité produit de la
différence voilà et tout ça décrit en
fait ce que doit être le monde de demain
et donc un grand et un vaste métissage
le blocage la conclusion rapidement en
fait la conclusion c'est que il faut
dépasser ce débat parce que ce débat
c'est un verrou les gens sont les deux
têtes sont d'accord sur un même point il
y a une disparition de la population
française soit c'est une merveilleuse
nouvelle soit c'est une catastrophe donc
ils sont d'accord mais ils sont pas
d'accord sur le plus et le moins et donc
il y a pas de débat possible il faut
revenir et c'est ça la clé la clé c'est
redonnons une dimension politique à ce
débat et je répète la formule
l'immigration est à la nécessaire et les
périlleuses si on arrivait juste à dire
ça ça serait formidable en tout cas vous
nous appelez à sortir de la morale on
n'a pas le temps de vous faire rêver
réagir c'est bien dommage mais vous
allez sans doute avoir un peu de temps
un tout petit peu plus pour la carte
blanche de Delphine Sabatier Delphine
vous vouliez revenir sur une conférence
de presque vous avez suivi celle de
Google face à chat gipiti l'entreprise
contre-attaque oui grande conférence
annuelle que vous avez peut-être suivi
aussi hier soir monsieur le ministre je
ne sais pas en tout cas pour résumer
Google c'est vraiment trouver une
nouvelle mission dans le monde rendre
l'intelligence artificielle
utile à tous donc il y va partout il en
met partout dans tous ses services et vu
le succès de ces services on va
difficilement y échapper juste un
chiffre combien de visites d'après vous
fait le moteur de recherche Google
on est à 88 milliards de visites par
mois donc c'est très impressionnant donc
saisie avec lesquels on va discuter
créer travailler demain apprendre même
ça va devenir une réalité très vite pour
énormément de monde alors concrètement
tout ça se concrétise comment alors
exemple vous sollicitez le moteur de
recherche au lieu de taper des mots clés
et bien vous allez pouvoir rédiger en
langage dit naturel vous avez posé la
question comme si vous parliez à un
assistant par exemple j'aimerais acheter
un vélo mais j'hésite encore sur le
modèle et puis j'aimerais connaître un
peu les prix et là l'assistant qui
s'appelle barre de chez Google et bien
va vous donner une réponse rédiger un
peu de la même manière comme si c'était
une vraie personne pour vous aider à
choisir autre exemple on a vu le cas
d'un email vous voulez envoyer un email
de réclamation pour obtenir un
remboursement et bien vous cliquez sur
elle peut me right qui veut dire
aide-moi à écrire et là vous indiquez
juste le but du mail il y a va s'occuper
de tout rédiger toute seule comme une
grande en deux secondes c'est plié vous
pouvez envoyer alors certainement que ça
va tâtonner quand même un petit peu au
début mais on est certain que saisias
vont vraiment changer beaucoup de choses
hier soir on a vu énormément de
démonstration impressionnante pour le
meilleur et pour le pire je voulais
parler de cette nouvelle génération d'IA
qui est capable de traduire dans
plusieurs langues ce que dit une
personne dans une vidéo je vous propose
de regarder la version originale en
anglais
alors voilà la version espagnole
regardez
il y a ce qu'elle fait c'est qu'elle
traduit mais en même temps elle va
intégrer en fait les mouvements délais
pour s'adapter au langage qui est choisi
par l'intelligence artificielle et
réplique les expressions du visage et
même le timbre de la voix alors comme
les inquiétudes pleuvent déjà je ne
cache pas que moi-même ça m'angoisse les
mauvais usages que l'on pourrait faire
de ces technologies Google prend les
devants et se présente un peu comme le
parangon du nia qui serait audacieuse et
responsable
des précautions pour l'instant en tout
cas ce qui est intéressant c'est que il
a annoncé qu'il réserverait ses
technologies de pointe dans la
génération de vidéos à des partenaires
autorisés uniquement et alors là-dessus
je voulais vous faire réagir monsieur le
ministre parce que je crois savoir que
vous n'étiez pas un moratoire sur le
développement technologique les
prouesses qu'en est-il de la stratégie
de Google est-ce que vous êtes pour
limiter les usages les accès vous avez
vraiment quelques secondes ce que je
peux dire c'est que le Parlement
européen a adopté aujourd'hui le texte
sur l'intelligence artificielle le
règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle les discussions vont
commencer entre le Conseil et la
Commission et l'Europe aura été la
première démocratie
très belle soirée documentaire portrait
de Georges keitzman qui nous a quittés
le grand avocat ancien ministre ne le
ratez pas ces signes qu'elle présent à
demain
[Musique]